[Music]
ryan is in bismarck north dakota hi ryan
how are you
i'm doing well sir how are you better
than i deserve what's up
uh so
my question is i'll start with that um i
just need to know kind of what to do
so right now i make about 25 000 a year
and i am getting government assistance
from medicaid and food stamps and
uh
government housing and stuff like that
and
if i make any more
then all of that goes away
and
if i make
more then i have to cover all of that
which would be about fifteen hundred
dollars a month
roughly so i would have to get another
job
to
make ends meet with that but i'm barely
making ends meet with it as i am now so
i guess my question would be should i
get another job and make more money or
should i kind of stay where i'm at and
kind of try and figure out where i can
go from here
where do you want to be in five years
and how is the short what's the best way
to get there
um basically i just want to be able to
spend the money that i make
you know i don't want to live paycheck
to paycheck and struggle through life
barely surviving i just want to be able
to you know what i'm i've made this
money i get to spend it hell i want
i'm not monetarily driven
so i don't necessarily want to be a
millionaire if you will but
i mean that would be nice but i'm not
super like i need to be a millionaire in
this many days
okay
well it's not the million dollars that
matters
it's what it does
it's not the uh the pile of money
whatever pile size pile money you want
to deal with that matters it's what it
does it gives you
freedom it gives you security it gives
you the ability to help others
uh none of which you have right now
right
if you take the government assistance
out of the picture and you called in and
said hey i made twenty five thousand
dollars should i keep making twenty five
thousand dollars or should i work so
that long term i can make more than that
and have control and have less anxiety i
would tell you to go get that other job
you're not gonna be working multiple
jobs forever right
hopefully
you're gonna find a job in a field that
you enjoy hopefully are you able to do
the kind of work that you want to do
um actually right now i'm detailing
vehicles and i kind of enjoy it you know
and that kind of means more to me than
a high-paying job is kind of enjoying
what i do why can't it be both you know
can't you detail cars and make a great
living
you're not wrong
there's a guy in my neighbor who charges
you know 300 bucks to detail a car he
can do two cars in a day
you can make it a lot more making a lot
more than twenty five thousand dollars
yeah
and so to me
working for somebody else detailing cars
are you doing them yourself
uh no i'm working for a company
okay
okay so let's and i i just make 25 000
because that's kind of my cap for
my medicaid and that kind of stuff
okay
so here's the thing
as long as you use the government
assistance
psychologically not a moral statement
but psychologically as a reason not to
go be successful
um then it's a bad thing we we want for
you ryan for you to be successful and
prosperous and have a really quality
life how old are you
uh 30 and i've got two babies okay all
right and so if i woke up in your shoes
what would i do and that's the way i
answer questions george answers
questions here on the show
um yeah you gotta feed your babies
that's your first thing
uh number two it is
valid that we do want to do something we
have some passion about and and are
working towards but what i don't hear
from you and you couched it under i'm
not monetarily driven is i don't hear a
lot of ambition
um and i want to give you a little bit
of that i want to inject a little into
you because of what it will bring to
your life
in other words i i would say let's let's
start setting some goals like i would
love to own my own detail company
uh by
uh 12 months from now because it really
doesn't take that much it's a pressure
washer and a thing of rags right and
it's a little bit of a solvent so i mean
you can do this and so and then you need
some clients and and make a lot more on
your own as a mobile detail guy with a
cheap pickup and a pressure washer
thrown in the back and whatever it takes
for you to go do that it does not
require a bazillion dollars in equipment
to start this business
and and let's go make sixty seventy
thousand dollars a year
doing that
instead of saying well i'm afraid if i
make a dollar more i won't get this
uh government stuff and so i'm kind of
trapped you're not trapped the only
thing only trapped you are is between
your ears
yeah that's a good word and ryan i think
you just need to set some of these goals
like dave's talking about and find that
passion because i think once you find
that if that's auto detailing that's
great go after that and don't the
government assistant's going to be in
the rear view mirror soon as you start
to make some great money with this and
you can make this maybe one day a
full-time gig
i mean it's not that you need to quit
the government assistance today but i
would set a goal that by the end of the
year i've changed my career i've changed
my job i've changed what i do or how i
do it to where i don't need the
government assistance anymore you do not
want to set your life up to where you
have a permanent depend on the
government because it's not going to
create a good life for you
you just don't meet people and go oh you
know i'm the happiest guy in my life i
mean i'm the happy scandal where i spent
50 years in subsidized housing it just
made me just made my life awesome this
these are not things that people say
dude
so yeah this is a thing you've got for
today and then you need to have a plan
to move away from it for your own
dignity your own prosperity your own
security
and your own growth your own personal
growth uh and so
it's a it's a good thing hey man i
appreciate you call i'm honored to have
you in the audience if we can help you
anyway let us know let me send you a
copy of ken coleman's book if he'll read
it kelly tell him and make sure he'll
read it it's called from paycheck to
purpose
from merely collecting a paycheck to
doing something with your life that has
purpose and oh by the way what george
said is exactly right
it's not mutually exclusive that you
have to not make money in order to be
happy as a matter of fact it's usually
quite the opposite when you're happy you
tend to make more money
that's the way it works
it's not just being a greedy capitalist
or something that's not the point it's
not a greed thing it's a i want to feed
my babies and have some security and
have some choices
thing it's a freedom thing